positive semi-fit and igen value
approximation this is Joint work with de
nidel and my postto Williams forworth so
um let me start by defining the problem
that we're going to study so we're given
a symmetric uh real valued Matrix a
let's say it's D byd uh so it has uh D
igen values and the question we're going
to ask is how many linear measurements
I'll say what those could mean in a
moment of a do we need to distinguish
between the following two cases one is a
is positive
semi-definite okay so all the non all
the igen values are non- negative and
two a has a sufficiently uh large
negative igen value those are the two uh
cases you want to
distinguish um yeah so PSD here is
symmetric and all non- negative igen
values um what are some example
situations where this problem might
arise so a could be the I of a loss
function f of a neural network evaluated
at some you know with some current
assignment of Weights let's say
x0 and in this case this uh Matrix a is
not given explicitly it's impractical or
INF feasible to write down the hen of a
large neural network um and this is
going to motivate us looking at this
Matrix a via these linear
measurements um and we maybe want to
distinguish between the cases that we're
minimizing a function f uh so is it
minimized at the current set of Weights
in that case the uh the hesan would be
PSD or uh is is it not is there a steep
descent Direction at the current
assignment of Weights so it has a large
negative igen value um and uh in this
particular application certain linear
measurements are very natural um so one
kind of linear measurement is a matrix
Vector product given a matrix a that we
don't have explicitly
we can still query it through vectors V
of our choice so we get to see a Time v
um and in this particular example it is
possible to get hesan Vector products
using automatic differentiation and
other techniques another kind of linear
measurement uh are um is a bilinear form
query I'll call the call it a vector
Matrix Vector query where you choose
vectors u and v on the left and the
right and You observe U transpose AV
um this is also well motivated for this
particular neural network application
where this corresponds to uh a single
second derivative uh directional
derivative calculation and it can be
approximated with a small number of
function queries so you know this is the
setting these are examples that we're
looking at also linear measurements come
up all the time in streaming and
communication settings as you know uh
they're they're useful because uh linear
sketches are easy to update and they're
mergeable and so on um okay so let me uh
formally Define uh the Epsilon LP tester
problem that we'll look at so given this
Matrix a implicitly if a is PSD uh we'd
like to declare that it's PSD with some
constant
probability and if a is Epsilon far from
PSD what that's going to mean that its
minimum igen value is less than minus
Epsilon times some matx Norm of a uh we
have this Gap depending on the norm so
that it's scale and variant okay and
this Matrix
Norm uh I've written a subp this is the
Shaden P Norm it's just the P Norm of
the igen values of your
Matrix okay so are you PSD or are you
sufficiently far from it in Shaden
pm and when PS2 this is the fbus norm so
we ask ourselves how many queries does a
tester need uh in these various models
Matrix Vector queries where we just
query with adaptively or or
non-adaptively with vectors v um Vector
Matrix Vector query as I said we're
going to focus on these two models
though you could also look at General
linear measurements where you just you
know take the dotproduct of your Matrix
uh entrywise with some uh other Matrix M
um as I said we're going to consider
both adaptive and non-adaptive testers
um adap
testers are motivated from uh you know
various optimization procedures that are
often performing things like a power
method or qulo Subspace iterations
non-adaptive testers are motivated from
streaming um and we aim to give tight
query complexity
balce
okay um so let's first look at Matrix
Vector
queries and let's look at P equals 1
okay um
and without loss of generality we can
assume that the uh one Norm is just the
sum of the absolute values of igen
values of your Matrix is one okay the
whole problem is scale and
variant okay so how can we tell if a is
PSD or it's it's it has a igen value
that's less than minus
Epsilon and here's what we're going to
do we're going to use uh what's called
the krylo iteration to approximate the
top igen value
not of the original Matrix a but of an
appropriately scaled and shifted Matrix
okay so let me say what happens here
here's your Matrix a in pictures okay so
this is the uh the
Spectrum um here's zero and a might have
a lot of uh positive igen values in fact
it might be PSD or there might be this
red uh negative IG value okay and we
want to know if this exists or not so
how can we figure out if it exists so we
can look at minus a that'll flip the
Spectrum around zero so now it looks
like
this we can then add a multiple of the
identity so I'm going to add Lambda
times the identity that'll shift all the
igen
values and so now this new Matrix has
all positive igen values if I choose
Lambda appropriately I'm going to choose
Lambda to be larger than the largest I
value of a the largest value of a is is
at most one because the the norm of a is
is
one now I have this new Matrix and my
goal is to estimate the uh top igen
value of this
Matrix um so I want to estimate this Top
igen Value up to additive Epsilon uh
error
here that that will tell me if this uh
Red Dot existed or
not now as we said Lambda could be as
large as as one so um what that means is
that we actually have to estimate the
Top igen Value up to a multiplicative
one plus or minus Epsilon
Factor okay in in you know in the worst
case and a good way to do this is with
the chish Chev trick okay so you can
estimate the top igen value of a matrix
with one over square root Epsilon Matrix
Vector uh
queries um so let me just review
that so assume that you have a PSD
Matrix
M then the idea is to choose a random
vector v maybe a a gan
Vector uh then just iteratively compute
v m * v m sare * V and so on M to the k
+ 1 time V this is an Adaptive
algorithm and once you have these Matrix
Vector
products um now you know how this uh uh
you you can combine these uh Matrix
Vector products to learn the uh any
polinomial of the igen
values uh so I I take any polinomial of
this Matrix M you know that just means I
apply the polinomial on the igen values
as long as the polinomial has degree at
most K okay so I learn P sub K of M time
V quite an appropriate combination of
these and the nice fact here is that
there exists a polinomial
p of degree uh K where K is uh Square <
TK Lambda 1 * 1/ root
Epsilon time log 1/ Delta such that this
polinomial well it's going to evaluate
to one on the top igen
value um and it's going to evaluate to
something really small in absolute value
so evaluate to a most Delta if I move a
little bit away from the Top igen Value
okay if I move Epsilon
away um and so this polinomial uh is
great you can think of it as just
maintaining the retaining the Top igen
Value and zeroing out all the other IG
values there a logarithmic dependence on
this
Delta um and uh
so if I look at this polinomial then uh
applying that to the Matrix M and
multiplying by V this is going to align
very well with the top igen value of M
okay because this P of M as we just said
is kind of like just the outer product
of the top IG IG Vector with
itself um and I I take the dot product
with with v and I get a vector which
really looks like the top ion
Vector um and so this qu of space
Witnesses the largest ion value to um to
to M um to within Epsilon additive error
which is what we
wanted uh and so we can just uh compute
these products and then uh maximize the
uh quadratic form to compute the top
igen Vector in the krylo space which we
know so we don't need to know this
polinomial to figure out uh a good bound
on the top I value okay all we need to
know is that this polinomial exists okay
because we can just optimize two the
best uh Vector in the kof space uh the
one that maximizes the dotproduct uh
with M and uh we already have all the
krylo uh we have the krylo space we have
all the Matrix Vector products we
need okay so this is very simple
algorithms uh and it gives one over root
Epsilon Matrix Vector
products um are there any questions
about
this okay do you think this is best
possible no no
okay I'm hiding log factors yeah
yeah
um okay why why do you say no or be over
okay um okay what what do you think we
might be doing uh
suboptimally what was one of sort of the
bottlenecks in this
algorithm yeah
like value close to one is where you
have this worst case guarantee but that
feels have some of tradeoff struct there
some of your Val has to be one yeah
that's exactly right so you know we we
had to shift a lot right potentially
shift by uh you know one times the
identity um so is there some way we
could avoid shifting so
much um and so the idea is well what if
we could somehow first deflate that is
zero out the largest few igen values of
this
Matrix and then perform this process so
then we would have to shift less because
you know if these uh I values go away
repeating the same procedure where we
negate and then shift we see that we
shift by less
here okay so maybe we can try to balance
the number of Matrix Vector products we
need to deflate together with this uh
you know this algorithm that we just
presented
so the idea is let's deflate the top T
values where T is going to be chosen to
be something like one over Epsilon to
the
1/3 um and I'll say how to do this in a
moment now we know that the sum of
absolute values of igen values is
one and so the new maximum igen value
after zeroing out the top
T has to be at most one over T which for
this setting is Epsilon to the
1/3
um and now if we go through the same
algorithm we just did on this deflated
Matrix a with the top ton values
removed then uh we don't have to shift
by as much we only have to Shi shift by
Epsilon to the 1/3 instead of
potentially
one and so now if you look at it from a
relative error standpoint we only need
to estimate the largest igen value up to
1 plus or minus Epsilon to the 2/3
multiplicative
error and now using the Chev trick on
this Matrix we only need the square root
of this which is 1 over Epsilon to the
1/3
queries okay um now I didn't say how to
do the deflation
yet uh deflation can be carried out
explicitly uh via Cameron and Chris's uh
algorithm analysis of
um Subspace iteration um but in fact
krylo just does this directly for for us
we don't need to do this
explicitly um so we can consider a
polinomial which instead of being degree
1 over Epsilon to the 1/3 that was this
Q ofx in the earlier algorithm
description this this this polinomial
that um you know if you unshift and go
back to the original matrix it's very
large value at the negative igen value
and roughly zero at all the positive IG
value vales so that's that polinomial q
and what we can do is we can force it to
be zero at the top T values um so that's
how we do the deflation we just multiply
by you know xus Lambda 1 xus Lambda 2
and so on and so we we choose the number
of uh values that we set to zero to be
the same as this original degree so the
overall degree just changes by a
constant Factor we also normalize uh by
a scaler here so that
uh uh P of the um the negative IG value
Still Remains one and you can show that
uh P evaluated at the smaller IG values
at the positive IG values is still very
small okay so you you have a low deegree
polinomial in the krylo space without
having to explicitly do the deflation
yeah you need estimates of Lambda 1 and
Lambda T to do this right no so you
don't actually need to know this
polinomial you just need to know that it
exists okay because in the end what
you're doing is you're going to build
build up this uh krylo Space by doing
these adaptive Matrix Vector products
you have this krylo space and now you
know there's some combination of the
Matrix Vector products that you have
that is uh you know that realizes the
polinomial applied to the Matrix and if
you were able to choose that that would
be great it would give you you know a
vector that's very aligned with the
negative igen Vector um you don't know
what that polinomial is but you have all
these Matrix Vector products so you can
just choose the best one in the space
that you have so it's a nice in the
sense that you just need to know that
this
exists any other questions yeah can you
also alternately oh can you also Al
alternately think of like a polinomial
that kind of zeros out the I'm interval
between um one and like something close
to Epsilon in the real
line um so well we I mean you wouldn't
be able to like zero out the interval
right but you could make it very small I
mean we don't really we don't need to do
anything beyond these top
yeah are there extremal results known
about like the optimality the degree the
polins uh I don't know like in terms of
like constant factors and logs I I I
don't know uh exactly what what what the
lower bounds are maybe someone else
knows anyone okay no yeah I think it's
optimal up to high order terms
yeah
any other
questions okay um yeah so this is what
the polinomial looks like right it zeros
these out uh and it's you know very
small on the positive IG values and it's
very large at this negative I value it
exists that's all we need to know um and
now we can just uh minimize the
quadratic form uh of a over the krylo
space and know that we'll get a a
negative value um and that's all we need
as a proof that this Matrix is not PSD
okay um yeah so that's it it gives one
over Epsilon to the 1/3 Matrix Vector
products um it's kind of a weird bound
uh you can generalize it to arbitrary uh
P Norms you get something uh like
Epsilon to the minus p over 2p + 1 this
this bound goes to it gets worse as P
increases it goes to one over root
Epsilon for large p and essentially what
that's saying is the deflation is not as
effective right if p is infinity then
you know deflating the top few igen
values well you could still have another
one of the same value um so this bound
it doesn't look very uh nice but in fact
it it's optimal so using a lower bound
technique of Braven at all um we can
show that this these bounds are tight in
this model um I'm not going to get too
much into it but they have a nice result
that says if you have a wishart matrix
uh so wishart has the form GG transposed
where G is Galan it's a d by D Matrix
and you want to estimate its smallest I
value up to a constant Factor then you
need d uh Matrix Vector queries okay so
the smallest igen value is not very
concentrated unlike the Top igen Value
and if you want to estimate it well then
you kind of need to read the whole
Matrix um uh and you can embed this
problem into our Problem by appropriate
setting of
parameters yeah it even for p equals
infinity uh for p equals infinity
Umar H yeah
so uh for non-constant p
um uh I don't know what the dependence
if there's a dependence here on P or not
I'd have to check yeah but I mean it
gets arbitr close for constant P
thanks um yeah this is com I think in
the in the P one which is what you
demonstrated yes there's a very similar
argument in the result of
move which basically says in the graph
setting if you have such a sum on values
conjugate gradient basically gets the
one like at least theoretically get a
cube roota conver which is the same oh
okay does it generalize to I mean the
construction of the Pol is the same
youly zero at the top roots and the
lower one and then now they smaller by
some okay okay yeah we should talk more
about that as yeah um okay so that's one
example of uh techniques here uh let me
um uh uh look now at bilinear sketches
so Vector Matrix Vector
queries um let's again look at P equals
1 we want to test if for PSD we far from
this a natural way of sketching is to
compute g g transpose where G is a gan
uh
Matrix um with hopefully a small number
of
rows and uh so the number of vector
Matrix Vector products here is one over
Epsilon squared if I have one over
Epsilon small dimension for
G um and uh if if a is PSD then Gad
transpose is also
PSD um and if uh a is far from PSD then
uh actually uh using analysis of andoni
and and H uh if it's Epsilon far you can
um show that uh uh it it won't be PSD
okay so you can just check if gag
transpose is PSD or not this has a nice
property of being a one-sided tester
meaning that when the input is PSD it
all always returns uh
PSD um and this is also optimal I I
won't say why um Okay so that's for p
equals 1 but what about uh P equals
2 and interestingly there's a there's a
very different Behavior here um so
there's a strong lower bound here that
no one-sided polinomial and one over
Epsilon uh L2 tester exists for M Vector
Matrix Vector uh
queries um and uh in fact you can show
that you need uh Epsilon to Theus 2 * D
Vector Matrix Vector queries okay so it
suddenly becomes polinomial in D once
you uh look at norms P larger than
one um and uh I'm not going to say what
the lower bound is but it's uh since
there's a streaming crowd here I want to
say that it's related to frequency
estimation arguments um in data streams
would say that if you um you know it's
well studied that you have a vector and
you want to produce a sketch of it to
approximate frequencies uh values in
that vector and um if you're required to
always produce overestimates of these uh
uh uh frequencies then the problem
actually becomes much harder okay so if
you're familiar with things like count
sketch these give you uh two-sided
estimates sometimes uh they're less than
the actual Valu sometimes they're larger
and that's actually essential if you
require one-sided then the space
complexity grows a lot and actually that
phenomenon is is related to what's
happening here um okay but that's just
for one-sided testers uh you know maybe
we can allow error uh two-sided
error um so let's try to diagnose the
problem what's happening uh here what is
the natural algorithm we can take the
algorithm of uh andoni and and who and
you know it's Computing gag transpose
and look at its igen values seems like a
natural thing to do the problem is that
uh uh the igen values of GAD transpose
are going to concentrate around the tra
of the Matrix
a which can be very large it can be
large as as large asot D the fbus
norm so you know unlike the simple
tester for p equals 1 where you just
check is there a negative igen value in
Gag
transpose um you're unlikely to observe
any negative igen values uh in the uh
case where your Epsilon far in the in
the torm um uh what's going to happen is
you're can to have a bunch of igen
values that concentrate around the trace
of
a and then maybe if you had a negative
igen value in the original Matrix well
maybe it'll be a little bit less than
the trace of a but it's you know it's
still going to be very
positive okay so the key idea that we
use is well maybe we can look at the
positions of the igen values relative to
the trace of
a okay um
and we're going to reject if you know
we're going to say G we're going to say
a is not PSD if gag transpose has a
suspiciously small looking igen
value um okay so formally what does this
mean uh let me just say roughly the
analysis goes so what we can show is
that if the original Matrix a has a
negative igen value smaller than minus
Epsilon then with good probability the
minimum igen value of G transpose is a
little bit away from the trace of a okay
so it's the trace of a minus at least
Epsilon time K where K is the number of
uh um rows in your Gan Matrix okay so
it's you know it's it's it's a little
bit negative it's a little bit far away
um uh let me not say much about the
proof but the the idea is just to choose
uh the vector closest in the uh image of
of G to the negative igen vector and you
can show you gain this little bit amount
okay I'm not going to say more um on the
other hand what you can show is that if
a is
PSD then actually uh all the igen values
of uh G transpose are within additive
root K from the
trace okay um and this uses uh a net
argument so we we um in fact we only
need the lower bound here because we're
going to try to distinguish we're going
to look at the minimum M value of the
sketch as our distinguisher we only need
the lower bound and so the idea is to
look at a net of all vectors v um in
this K dimensional space and use H and
right inequality um to to you know it's
concentrated and you know with the
appropriate inequality you can lower
bound how much you deviate from the
expectation um and and that's it so the
idea is if you're Epsilon far from PSD
you can show the minimum igen value is a
little bit far away from the trace of a
on the other hand if your PSD the
minimum igen value is somewhat close to
the trace of a you then choose your
number K of measurements to separate
these two cases and if you just solve
you see that you need your Gan Matrix to
have one over Epsilon squar uh small
Dimension um and uh yeah so the idea is
just compute the minimum igen value of
the sketch in parallel you need to
estimate the trace of a that can be done
easily with known algorithms and then
you just check at this minimum igen
value how close it is to the trace to
your estimate of the trace
okay um and that's one over Epsilon to
the fourth Vector Matrix Vector
queries um uh because it's g d transpose
and that actually turns out to be
optimal as well
um any questions about this this
algorithm yeah
uh yeah so when you talk about uh
concentration around the trace is is
there assumption here that
dimensionality is just much larger than
K and this why this is the case because
if they're proportional then it wouldn't
concentrate right yeah I'm thinking of K
as you know being something that's you
know much smaller than the uh The Matrix
Dimension you're trying to sketch and
reduce it
[Applause]
yeah other
questions okay um don't have much time
left so let me just you know just give
you a flavor of other techniques in this
area very quickly um we saw that uh for
L1 testing there's this bilinear sketch
Gad transpose that has one of repon
squared Vector Matrix Vector
measurements that was andoni algorithm
um you could ask yourself can you
improve this with adaptivity I said it
was tight if it's
non-adaptive um and in fact you get one
over Epsilon measurements with
adaptivity and to me it's kind of
surprising because I haven't seen
algorithms uh of the form of vector
Matrix Vector queries that exploit uh
adaptivity usually it's like you know
these krylo methods you know Matrix
times Vector Matrix times vector and so
on but um so how how do we do this
what's the rough
idea the idea is well we're trying to
minimize this quadratic form X transpose
ax right we're trying to see if this
value ever gets negative that means it's
it's not
PSD and we're going to run a kind of
cheap uh gradient descent here which
uses very few Vector Matrix Vector
queries um and here's the idea we're
going to initialize a vector to be
Galan and we're just going to do the
following
iteration um the new iterate at time k+1
is the old itate minus an unbiased
estimate of the
gradient um a nice thing about this
unbiased estimate is uh there's only one
vector Matrix Vector query here so you
choose a gan at the case step and you
look at Gan transpose times Matrix times
your previous iterate that's your single
Vector Matrix Vector query and you
multiply that by the Galan you chose
okay so there's only one query to a here
it's an unbiased estimate of the
gradient because if you look at GG
transpose the expectation is the
identity
and uh what you can show is this
algorithm if you run it for one over
Epsilon iterations with high probability
you will actually choose an iterate uh
find an iterate which Witnesses which
shows the quadratic form is actually uh
negative um so uh that's one way of
using adaptivity here um any questions
about
this okay and finally let me just say
one more thing is that um this study
into testing of PSD matrices uh led to
new algorithms for spectrum estimation
so approximating all the igen values of
a
matrix um so here's the problem
statement assume you have a symmetric D
byd Matrix a not necessarily
PSD your goal is to construct a sketch
of a to recover the igen
values um and what we want to do is we
want to estimate every original igen
value of a up to additive Epsilon times
the fbus norm of
a so this is going to be good for igen
values that are large for very small IG
values the estimates are not going to be
interesting it'll just be zero but that
is for good reason okay you can't
actually estimate very small IG values
well with small sketching
Dimension um so the question is how
small can a sketch be and previous work
uh that I me mentioned uh shows you can
do this with 1 Epsilon to the 6 uh
Vector Matrix Vector queries uh you know
it's this g g transpose sketch with one
over Epsilon Cube small dimension on
both sides but it has some drawbacks in
the sense that the sketch can't actually
recover the signs of the igen values it
loses that information inherently
um and uh so what we we show is that by
taking this approach uh for for testing
but our analysis of GAD transpose but
what we can do is um subtract off the
trace that's the sort of uh you know
most concise description um so we look
at Gad transpose the same sketch um and
uh the expected value uh of its Trace is
the original Trace but now it only has K
Dimensions so the igen values average at
one over K times the trace of a instead
of one over D times the trace of a
and we correct for this by subtracting
off 1 over K times the trace of a times
the identity so we have our sketch and
we subtract off a multiple of the
identity to try to correct for
this um and so this is the whole
algorithm and I'll just end with this uh
it's a very simple algorithm for
estimating igen values um two is a gan
Matrix G with roughly one over Epsilon
squ rows compute the sketch G A
transpose really small 1 over Epsilon
squ by 1 Epsilon s and just output the
igen values of this
sketch minus uh this multiple of the
identity trace of a over K compute those
igen values you're only going to get K
of them and you want to estimate D
values for the original Matrix for all
the remaining igen values just estimate
them with zero this algorithm Works uh
it's simple it's easy to implement and
it gives optimal uh sketching Dimension
um and let me just uh conclude then um
so we gave tight bounds for PSD testing
and Spectrum estimation under natural
measurement models there are lots of
nice questions here our proof for
spectrum estimation requires the
sketching matrices to be gussian uses
gaussianity in several places uh uses
rotational invariance uh to imply
independence of certain quantities we
don't know if you can use uh sparse
sketching matrices uh that would speed
it up um
we don't know if adaptivity helps for
spectrum estimation um in terms of
vector Matrix Vector queries so we got a
tight one over Epsilon to the fourth
bound maybe you can do better with
adaptivity and there are also other
models for PSD testing instead of just
having one large negative IG value maybe
you have a lot of negative igon value
Mass but no particularly large one what
can you do in that setting so that's all
thank
you running a bit over time so maybe one
question question before our next
[Applause]
speaker